so Wi-Fi is a wireless way of getting
access to internet and as a result we're
bombarded by these radio waves. So can we use
them to say something about the environment?
because these signals interact with
objects so we have this very natural
question, how much can they tell us about
the environment? we basically wanted to see x-ray
vision with Wi-Fi.
so imagine there is an area where walls
and behind those wars there's an object
lets say two robots move outside of the
area, one is transmitting a signal with a
wifi card and the other is receiving it and
that transmission goes through the object in
in a sense we could say they leave a signature on
the signal and that signature is
what we're trying to use and from that
reception figure out something about the
object and the more measurements they
can collect they can do that imaging
better. That means being able to tell you
the location of objects, the geometry in
shape we've shown that you can actually
do this.
but we actually could do a little bit
more because what we extract also tells us
something about the material properties
and so what we hope is that in the
future should be able to say something
more about what kind of object is there.
An application could be search and rescue. So imagine Japan's tsunami in 2011, in
such a scenario, for instance, a nuclear spill
and is too dangerous for humans to go in
it would be great if we can have unmanned
vehicles that from outside can assess
the situation inside and figure out
what's going on inside behind and then
help guide humans to safe areas
what did you think of the video let us know
in the comments below and make sure to
subscribe to figure 1